parlons-en mathieu denis vous êtes allé
l'interroger
il a accepté absolument il brosse un
portrait de sa mère
si agnès était si agnès était une
héroïne film
ça serait lara croft dans un champ de
patates
[Musique]
c'était une image d'épinal ce n'est pas
une image d'épinal ce serait un ex voto
[Musique]
du made in love de la race par exemple
parce que c'est une très belle chanson
d'amour et on n'est pas là pour se faire
engueuler de boris vian
parce que dans le travail ça rigole pas
[Musique]
le marathon se le s'arrête jamais alors
si c'était un plat du mosad filet de
dorade pâtisserie du genre vous souvenez
en indoor à dans les soirs
un vêtement
une robe à pois sans hésiter si c'était
une lueur jeudi rennes
beau temps mais orageux vous êtes
d'accord vous êtes d'accord et tout ça
répond entièrement d'accord quand quand
il allait dire l'épreuve sportive je me
suis dit pour moi ce sera un marathon il
a dit à marc attend alors sur leurs
pages j'ai pas compris parce que vous
faisiez trop de bruit mais sur la
nourriture
ça m'étonne qu'il ait pas dit aubergines
mais c'est parce qu'il a dit il a parlé
du du menu qui était plus un peuple être
mais le dessert du chef chez pas s'il a
repris mais les autres choses qu'il a
dites il a oublié le son le fromage de
chèvre non mais est ce qu'ils me
connaissent bien quand même
c'est quand on s'aime justement je crois
quand on s'aime bien on se connaît bien
et ça permet d'aimer sans être aveugle
et sans tabou et et vous avez toi et
déjà d'être abusés quand on est un peu
ensemble
vous avez enfin dans un briefing qui
faisait quoi là quand il était petit je
me suis jeté sur lui tant que j'ai pu la
tournée à 4 ans dans l'une chante il a
tout tournait à 9 ans dans documenteur
avec la barre qui n'ont plus tard à 14
me sentais comme pomas avec jim bien qui
ils râlent un peu là alors après il a
dit surtout à tout jamais qui ne
trouverait plus que ça mais il a quand
même tourné dans les sens une nuit vous
donner des conseils aujourd'hui ah non
surtout que j'en pense pas mais vous
n'osez pas mais vous adoriez j'aimerais
des fois quand par hasard à charles
lâcheur je me fait rabrouer alors
terriblement il a raison attendez c'est
pas tellement facile déjà des djeun de
se trouver de faire le métier c'est pas
forcément facile d'avoir deux parents
qui danse cinéma se sont fait remarquer
même si on n'est pas tellement connu et
tout ça et c'est vrai que il a envie de
faire ça il a fait son premier court
métrage il a bien fait et j'avais la
trouille un petit peu on a forcément un
petit peu la trouille je me disais
pourvu que ce soit bien quoi et
professionnellement vous voulez écouter
oui parce que tout est curieusement ce
garçon qui est un peu fantasque qui est
rigolo qui est plein d'humour qui est
intelligente mais qui est fragile qui
est sensible et tout ça au fond quand
j'ai un vrai souci c'est à lui en parle
et il est d'un conseil cette
extraordinaire
tout d'un coup il ya une sagesse en lui
je comprends pas d'où ça vient
[Musique]